bienvenidos a star trek san josé de mayo
mi nombre es paola pacheco y hoy los
invito a conversar respecto a qué es lo
que pensamos sobre los videojuegos
porque cuando uno piensa generalmente en
todo lo que tiene que ver con entrenando
a la cabeza con entre nuevamente con
trabajarla lo que ahora faltan no está
nombrado la plasticidad cerebral esa
capacidad tan necesaria
que tenemos que desarrollar el largo de
toda nuestra vida para adaptarnos de la
mejor manera a los diferentes cambios
que vamos a ir viviendo como seres
humanos desde nuestra infancia hasta
nuestra vejez
porque siempre pensamos en cualquier
otra cosa pero nunca pensamos en
videojuegos y lo que pensamos cuando
pensamos de los juegos generalmente
call of duty igual son formas e ipex no
sé qué videojuego juegan sus hijos los
niños que conocen los adolescentes que
conocen
y qué es lo que les viene a la mente a
la cabeza cuando piensan o cuando ven a
esos chicos jugando sus videojuegos
seguramente no tienen absolutamente nada
que ver con todo lo que hablamos recién
del plasticidad cerebral la plasticidad
cerebral entrenar el cerebro y demás
bueno
otra cosa que tenemos que preguntarnos
es tienen fundamento esas cosas que
queremos porque está buenísimo esto de
ser adultos pero porque tenemos que ser
adultos que ven con esa mirada
inquisitiva lo que nos vienen a mostrar
nuevas generaciones cuando en realidad
la ciencia hoy en día nos demuestra que
es todo lo contrario de los fantasmas
que nosotros tenemos
y hay informes como los de las negros
científicas daphne bavelier que se los
recomiendo ampliamente inclusive hay
varias charlas ted en la vuelta que ella
dio que echan por tierra absolutamente
todo eso que nosotros tenemos los rollos
sueltos creemos como adultos serios y
responsables que somos que los
videojuegos son
para personas que son antisociales o que
nos vuelven antisociales o que nos dejan
estúpidos o que perdemos el tiempo
que más pensamos pregúntense ustedes que
yo es lo que piensan cuando piensan en
videojuegos vuelve los informes el
informa casi todas por daphne bavelier
que es sobre el impacto que tienen los
videojuegos de acción
porque otra de las cosas que este
informe también detalla de mano de babel
es que no todos los videojuegos tienen
el mismo impacto en el cerebro
si tienen todo lo que hacemos tiene un
impacto en el cerebro pero no todos los
videojuegos en este caso tienen el mismo
impacto ella analiza el impacto que
tienen los videojuegos de acción como
esta visión es mencionada como cada
producto
y entre las cosas maravillosas que se
encontraron en este informe
es que sirve además para lograr trabajar
lo que es la agudeza visual
en personas incluso por ejemplo que
sufren de ambliopía es una pérdida de la
visión este por una falta de
sensibilidad de retina pero que no
necesariamente va asociadas a causas
orgánicas
y notaron que las personas que tenían
determinadas patologías visuales
y que jugaban videojuegos lograban una
mejoría en esa agudeza visual
sobre todo porque lo que se daban cuenta
era de que la información que el cerebro
empezaba a recibir este de la parte
posterior era información más más
legible se volvían mucho más este
sensibles inclusive a las diferencias de
grises
otra de las cosas también que el informe
de viabilidad descubrió es que las
personas que jugaban en videojuegos de
acciones en los estudios que le hiciera
una serie de estudios para medir la el
desarrollo cognitivo y las capacidades
intelectuales esas personas mostraban
que estas personas que jugaban
videojuegos frente a las que no los
jugaban lograban mejores resultados y
sobre todo algo que a las mamás ya sí a
muchos padres les preocupa es que los
videojuegos
les quiten o distraiga a sus hijos de
las cosas prioritarias como el estudio
como lo forma lo académico
el informe de babel y lo que demuestra
es que quienes jugaban videojuegos a
nivel académico tenían la capacidad de
poder este discernir mejor y sacar del
medio todo lo que eran distracciones
todo lo que era información secundaria
que no estaba relacionada directamente
con el objetivo que tenían que cumplir
puntualmente en cada ejercicio que les
iban poniendo
entonces me parece que todos este tipo
de informes y esta esta información tan
valiosa que nos aporta hoy la
neurociencia sobre el impacto de los
videojuegos en el cerebro es algo que
nos tiene que servir como puntapié para
cuestionarnos si realmente los
prejuicios que tenemos sobre los
videojuegos son prejuicios reales o si
es en realidad fundado por nuestra
frustración muchas veces al momento de
lidiar con 'la como adultos con la
tecnología
tengo 42 años y hace prácticamente 30
años que juegos videojuegos arrenta
jugando el mítico super mario
después de que por un largo tiempo y
retome hecha por el 2009 con un juego
de disparos en primera persona que se
llamaba al dial tournament
hoy en día llevo infinidad de horas de
juego de lo que se conoce en bastión
real como force night o call of duty
works on
paralelamente a eso se una vida de
familia estudio una carrera y raíz un
montón de otras tareas que tienen que
ver con lo comunitaria
tal vez si yo no hubiera tenido este
pasaje por los videojuegos mi visión del
mundo sería muy distinta a la que tengo
hoy en día y tal vez no podría estar hoy
acabando con usted de este tema por eso
antes de irme me gustaría compartir
algunos puntos que tienen que ver con la
importancia de los videojuegos y las
cosas que uno puede aprender de ellos y
ponerlos en práctica en la vida misma en
el día a día como individuos de una
sociedad como ciudadanos como familiares
como padres como hijos como hermanos
como amigos todo eso hay un montón de
cosas que los videojuegos nos enseñan y
que me gustaría conversar con ustedes
antes de irme
primero que nada los videojuegos nos
enseñan a pensar a corto y largo plazo
cuando nos pueda por ejemplo call of
duty o un forma que uno sabe que los
espacios para guardar armas para guardar
materiales son limitados entonces esté
todo no se puede tener uno tiene que ser
sabio el momento de elegir entonces en
la vida yo les propongo que llevemos eso
a cabo
no nos quedemos en la chiquita quienes
queremos ser que queremos hacer no
importa tiene que ver sobre nosotros
tiene que ver sobre un proyecto personal
un proyecto de disfrute un proyecto de
lo que sea bueno pensémoslo a corto pero
pensemos lo a largo plazo también íbamos
a necesitar llevar que de que podemos
prescindir en ese viaje para poder
acercarnos más rápidamente el objetivo
todo no lo podemos tener no podemos
llevar la alforja todas llenas de armas
de municiones de lo que sea en el juego
bueno en la vida es lo mismo no podemos
llevar todo
voy hablando de bitácora los objetivos y
la bitácora tienen que estar siempre a
mano yo tengo que tener en claro hacia
dónde voy
cuando yo empiezo una partida en un
videojuego yo ya vengo de antemano
sabiendo que es cuáles son las misiones
diarias que yo tengo que cumplir para
llegar a determinados objetivos para
después poder llegar a una misión
mensual a una misión semanal pero todo
eso anda pasado ha pegado una cosa con
la otra entonces es súper importante que
yo mis objetivos sean de los que sean
sean a nivel personal sean profesional
de la índole que sea yo los tenga
siempre a la vista que yo los puedan
medir
y otra cosa muy importante es vincular
los objetivos que hace un gamer es
cambiar la estrategia pero no cambia
nunca el objetivo el objetivo cuando uno
lo elige es por algo por algo llegó por
algo elige una carrera por algo eligió
hacer tal cosa por algo tomó una
decisión de vida el objetivo es
importante el objetivo siempre hay que
defender sobre todo cuando es elegido
por uno mismo
no conozco otra forma elegida pero dices
bueno este pueden darse otros casos
cualquiera sea el caso lo importante es
que sea elegido con una misma y que uno
cambie la estrategia cambia de camino no
importa esas cosas hacer como el agua ir
variando uno lo hace cuando está jugando
en medio de un mapa pero no cambia los
objetivos elegir las batallas a veces
nos pasa a nosotros en los jugadores
perdón para él
como jugadores
de pronto vamos camino a nuestro
objetivo tenemos que cumplir una misión
y en el camino nos encontramos con otro
escuadrón con el que no preveíamos y
tenemos que tratarlos afaco de un lado
bueno en ese sentido a veces tenemos que
evaluar nos vale la pena entrar en
combate nos vale la pena arriesgar lo
que ganamos hasta ese momento por
ejemplo si hablamos del modo saqueo de
los punto iguales son pero tiene que ir
recolectando botines este y después
depositados en un banco en la vida lo
mismo hay que evaluar hay veces que nos
va a pasar que nos vamos a encontrar en
el camino con personas que aparentan ser
nuestros enemigos o con personas con las
que tenemos diferencias y uno tiene que
plantearse vale la pena entre una
confrontación de que forma como como
enfrentó este conflicto
es elegir las batallas nuestra energía y
nuestro tiempo son muy valiosos y eso un
gamer lo sabe porque las partidas tienen
su tiempo y se termina el tiempo
determinado a partir de que este es el
lugar que quedaste entonces mi consejo
como veis en este sentido es elijan las
batallas que van a perder que van
perdón te van a jugar
tercer cambio constante es cambiar los
mapas lo que más no sabemos cambian
mapas también armas también la
jugabilidad dentro del juego cambia las
texturas cambia todo entonces este hay
que ir siempre es un aprendizaje
constante todo el tiempo cada vez que yo
esté con tiempo ocioso o cuando mi mente
se esté yendo a un lugar que de repente
yo no quiero que se vaya preguntarme que
podría estar aprendiendo en este momento
que me haría a mí mejor y me daría
mayores herramientas para llegar a ese
objetivo bueno entonces me tocó poner
aprender ahora eso es aprendizaje
constante
eso es adaptarme a el cambio constante
que pasa dentro de un juego y pasa en la
vida real también
y por último el mayor aprendizaje es el
aprender a fallar recién cometido un
furcio y decía elija en las batallas que
van a perder
uno tiene que aprender a perder en la
vida
y uno tiene que aprender a ganar todo el
circunstancial como en un juego
pero el aprendizaje mayor que a mí me
dejó a los videojuegos es lo que se
conoce como tráigame intenta de nuevo
anda de nuevo perdiste te fue mal pero
que sacaste de esta partida que quite
cosas nuevas que información tenes que
la puedes usar y cuando respondía cuando
volvés a jugar de nuevo otra partida
similar la podes aplicar y te va a dar
la ventaja que antes no tenías
pero inténtalo no te quedes solamente
con el fracaso porque un fracaso no te
define como persona y los gei más los
sabemos si no imagínate que nos
podríamos jugar la cantidad de horas de
juego que jugamos y la cantidad de
juegos diferentes que jugamos
entonces tráigame cada vez que la vida
te diga un game over
vos de un try again